greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by blue apron blue apron is deleting
milk it delivery service in the US and
while many people know what we do many
don't know about the types of meals you
can eat when you cook with blue apron
alright you just not having burgers for
dinner you're making a short rib burger
with hoppy cheddar sauce on a pretzel
bun you prepare and see it steaks with
thyme pan sauce and mashed potatoes
green beans and crispy shallots for 45
minutes without a trip to the grocery
store you understand me blue apron is
the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in this country
so do me a favor go check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals at blue apron comm slash Joey for
free you like Joey what are you talking
about listen your first three meals at
blue apron calm slash Joey I'm free blue
apron a better way to cook number two
you're a fat [ __ ] you athletic whatever
you need a new gig you need a new
mouthpiece you need a new [ __ ] mat
for your house gym whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do go to Fuji sports.com right
now why why Joey why should I go there
look I'll tell you why
quality that's why quality you ever go
for sushi and they beat you not a Fuji
Sports these Japanese people legit they
don't [ __ ] around you understand me they
don't [ __ ] around you need a new tough
gig Fuji Sports is there you need match
you need [ __ ] shin guards whatever
[ __ ] you need Fuji Sports has been there
since nineteen something and don't
matter trust what I'm telling you people
tug on me they choke me to death the
Fuji ski is tougher than [ __ ] Dutch
I've had G's people have ripped off my
back the Fugees still there go to Fuji
Sports calm and press ENTER and get 10%
off the living right to your [ __ ]
house like a doctor you understand me
you know the last game I'm gonna give a
little bit to it sounds like Bruce Lee
something some little Chinese girl
brought it to his house nice and I
understand me kick that [ __ ] me Lee
we got sim Corinne in the [ __ ] house
in ministry 8 we got that Christ killer
here
we got the drummer from ministry sitting
on the sidelines here nice and gentle me
don't say much people don't say much
okay I'm done it's a good drummer
[ __ ] just play the drummer's
like the the punters of the football
team
drummers no no the punters control the
[ __ ] game yeah but some of them would
drive you crazy the best ones are the
ones that just drum just shut the [ __ ]
up and drum there's a line of coke he's
dropping as Red Bull and milk do what
you need to do yeah and get your head
together this summe ice cubes in the
freezer yeah brother that is my problem
and there's what people don't know but
I'm honest about it sometimes somebody
calls me and they go hey man we have
this guy's an interesting cat and you
know I Wikipedia and Wikipedia he's [ __ ]
it's like a bag exactly and it's like me
coming back to you ill so Joe you're not
arrested for burglary here in 87 me
you know what it'll give us a [ __ ] right
but once you start following people and
you see them in action you're the
coolest [ __ ] out here
I appreciate like I thought Rudy was
cool rudy is cool as [ __ ] you bust it
one day you swap and spit at the Grammys
then then the next day you pop up with a
mandolin maybe onstage couple chubby
chicks or faint in front you like the
Beatles when they first got over the
Kenny yeah you had a couple chubby
chicks with tattoos those little chubby
chicks at concerts they suck dick they
stop eating they intermittent fasting
guitar oh my god they don't give a [ __ ]
those little chubby girls at tattoo I
love you and [ __ ] at the shows here man
fast oh they hit the mid fast it's
drinking they get [ __ ] up and then
somebody's gonna get hurt you understand
me yeah it's been interesting that's
interesting it's been an interesting
road and yeah I mean thank God that you
know people still show up and and give a
[ __ ] you know what I'm doing and what
the bands are doing and [ __ ] but you
know how it is man on the road it's it's
crazy man you see all kinds of [ __ ] out
there but they say it's a good night
lifestyle when you live and your
grandmother's basement you find the job
that covers the spread yep you know
there's nothing like being 19 the tree
and just living or 29
completing this is a complete different
disaster thank you the 23 is the [ __ ]
life absolutely especially if you just
said [ __ ] college yeah I'm gonna play
the guitar I'm gonna get a job in the
hardware store yeah and go see bands at
night four nights a week you know
whatever the [ __ ] you do like I grew up
with guys that that was their lifestyle
that's their lifestyle today yeah I
don't condemn it at all yeah they have a
great time but to go see bands four or
five nights a week you know that's heavy
duty that's a lot of dough yeah that's a
lot of drugs during the week yeah
there's some nights you get off stage
11:30 you go right home yeah and you get
up and you deliver towels whatever the
[ __ ] it is that you do just to co-exist
yeah it's such a complete different
happiness and then one day life starts
getting serious your grandpa tells you
you're a [ __ ] sack of [ __ ] you got to
move out of 43 he was killing [ __ ]
Japanese people 23 I was stabbing
Japanese people I was little I was in a
Hitler [ __ ] nut and I'm saying
singing Jews oh my god any other hunt
I met a [ __ ] dude that was talking
loud one day like yeah and I couldn't
handle it back dad like Howard this is
way before calmly now around me his
numbers on his arm and she drop yeah
Lamar he was drunk one night this guy
yeah he was telling me he was one of
hitlers hudson duty in there you know
that's a [ __ ] nightmare when you have
those people live in concert those poor
Jews two bottles of Manischewitz they
take you into murky waters you gotta do
18 eight balls just to coexist you go
home more depressed and watchin
Eyewitness News this is 40 minutes of oh
my god I never seen that before
Wow I still remember the bar in New York
not the name of where the first time I
met a Holocaust survivor one who was
Hamid
he was happy yeah they rewrite the beer
yeah if he didn't have the numbers on
his arms I would he had everything like
number man just broke it down and you
know I was listened to his story
I started getting sad I could just
minding me a very thing bad in my
[ __ ] life sure I'll even know how we
talked about with our survivors what
[ __ ] Marquez ends up on Holocaust one
opens
I'm talking about this is this is no
bueno I think it was a [ __ ] I
think I think I thank God we don't need
other moves no more on the show now at
least we're coherent we're coherent at
least we do two three bond hits over
these [ __ ] happy that knows those
other Bulls would kill people Eve keep
on Joe you lost so much weight cuz I
stopped teen edibles eaten that well you
go home and you just lose control yeah I
got was sitting there one night thinking
about how I used to kill that
refrigerator my wife would buy those
packages of salami yeah she's like the
last two or three days no they won't
like t3 albert's I would kill those
packages I would kill the whole I can
just allow me and half the bagans of
American cheese damn two bags of popcorn
three bags of popcorn graham cracker
though you know and you start lightly
give you eat lie to yourself
yeah I gotta yell dirt with strawberries
and some [ __ ] nuts whether I'm
healthy
you start with that and then it was just
I just going through the worst foxhole
in my life so I stopped with the animals
I lost 30 [ __ ] pen that's how much
Wow how much those edibles when you stop
gradually but they weren't that strong
the edibles I am more for the flavor
this guy I know this guy I know makes a
[ __ ] beef jerky an edible way mignon
oh he said his wife this tie must I tell
you anymore
Wow [ __ ] dope sit up he says there's
like a hundred milligrams per package
per ounce hmm you know yesterday two
packages I had to kill them all my
weight watcher points yeah I have these
weight watcher points left alright so I
might as well kill him use him here I
walked around a little bit yesterday so
I said he killed his jerky just to see
what it does to me oh [ __ ]
it was good I passed out two hours in
the afternoon nice
that's how I took a nap you stopped two
week uh-huh I mostly I did it I was
tongue you guys before the podcast I
there's been a couple of times where I
get too high and it's not even because
that happens every time with me is is
you probably starts a GPA we know you're
low potassium only - yeah that's it
we're done our tolerance
our tolerance was so high sinned it was
we were taking 1600 it was ugly kind of
like night it was really ignore because
there was at what time I was just
poisoning well like I would get him in
the end old and get the 180 the Chiba
choo uh-huh and I would take the wrapper
off the 180 and put it in a 65 now him
it was a 16 and he would eat half of it
and it was really 90 and he would get
[ __ ] up and then there was a cookie
that was really 200 but I told it was a
hundred he did half of it so I was
building his tolerance he has you know I
did that's one word for oh my god can't
you're in training oh yeah that we did
nothing oh my god we did the we equalize
we both kinda why did I put [ __ ]
little heroin dust in the bong and you
see see the dog so what was it that bad
what was it they gave Pauly Shore I've
had a ball just need a little because he
just he didn't even have the whole thing
know that star is true and he liked it
that really [ __ ] yeah right that time
those stars are still like these stars
you reading the whole - yeah you put
them in the freezer that's six months oh
we haven't gotten a started yeah they
might be long older than that holders of
that so they're really concentrated now
don't take you to it it's I get that
good explain if I eat like a Viking in
that's two years old and you're filing
an old yet surgery like like and you
[ __ ] find the Viking you let me see
this [ __ ] works I guess it works good it
will work it will have you burping and
[ __ ] like that bit who gives a [ __ ] you
know man you look at a guy and you play
some of the band in your head you think
he has this weird lifestyle have you yet
seen Steven Tyler I'm Joe Rogan I did I
did I didn't watch the out of that you
know I dug it I think Steven I mean he's
a character he's the real deal
he's the real like he's not there's no
yeah that's not an a that is him and I
mean we played we played with Aerosmith
last June at the Download Festival in
the UK
I mean we you know we get to see a
different side of that we get to see a
lot of the the behind the scenes stuff
but he I had a great time watching that
podcast Joe's podcast with Stephen cuz
he just so the dudes like on 11
constantly and he's such a like
eccentric dude but it's not an act it's
not fake it's really who he is like he's
really going a thousand miles an hour
constantly and that really is how he
lives his life like he's constantly he's
everywhere
well you really know and he read his
timeline no dude yeah I know his
schedules like it's it was ridiculous
it's insane I wish that's my schedule if
you haven't they yeah right you wish
that's your schedule he's 70 years old
dude and he does not do his schedule I
don't know if you saw that podcast or
not he was like going down like his very
it is like every hour he's got like
pretty much something going on and he's
traveling he's flying he's like going
everywhere red eyes yes yes 70 red eyes
yeah I'm 55 I take a red I'm crushed
with three [ __ ] yeah days yeah it was
amazing to watch dude it really was you
know when you given me like a band that
you like you start talking to the singer
these nuns asurela stool the [ __ ]
shed constantly oldest end of the bass
players just as goofy oh yeah and then
there's one guy in the band that's a
kind of Phi Beta Kappa yeah this
[ __ ] hos everything you could
tell he's the one that does everything
for the band
yeah well that was looking at Steven
Tyler this is what I kept thinking about
like I remember walking to Secaucus New
Jersey summer of 76 or 77 to see journey
Aerosmith and Ted Nugent Wow
and I can't even tell you the undercard
the undercard was like Frank Marino and
mahogany rush Wow poco Dan was just it
was just an all-day festival one of
those 12 o'clock yeah Aerosmith is
taking the stage at 7:00 and I gotta
tell you something right now the band
that was a sight like my friends were
excited for Ted
I was more excited for Aerosmith how
does the fan of at that time I was a fan
of rocks and the one with big tendon
shiny toys in the ad and what I don't
even know what the [ __ ] I was a fan of
yeah but I wasn't a fan of get your
wings yet okay alright that's the second
right that became my all-time favorite I
went down there and Aerosmith was so
[ __ ] bad journey was amazing journey
to miss a note I will submit when I'm
tenth fell apart at the seams everybody
else nobody else is great then they
broke the guitar like for no reason you
didn't do nothing to excite me to break
the [ __ ] [ __ ] and then Ted went on
and just destroyed tens of this prime
right 76m ah yeah now I'm that you know
I'd have a walk-in home and feeling bad
for Aerosmith but going back to see them
like I went back to see them some other
time and just as bad well just as bad
like when they released night at the
ruts a little bit before and I had two
runs and then they released that the
ruts and they fell apart Joe Perry
laughs Brad Whitford left right and I
went to see him again but now guys it
wasn't the stadium and it wasn't the
theater in the city it was the same bar
that Twisted Sister Holly [ __ ] all these
people were playing and we called the
soap factory in Richfield Park or
finally apart one of those parks New
Jersey yeah and he was really I mean the
tickets were like 12 bucks or something
and then and it was him with the new
guitar player and a new bass and they
were just [ __ ] he was high Wow and
what I remember the most from that -
there was a guy standing in front of me
and he was not none Harold and he kept
having a cigarette in his hand but it
was 1977 76 78 and hence the age of the
halter top only old people know if
there's a home the top is like me had a
woman gets into and she doesn't wear a
bra under that tube and the tits would
be banging you'd see the nipples but the
back would be exposed yeah
so every friend this junkie would nod
I'd push him into a girl and he would
burn her back with a say
and the girl would turn around and haul
off his smack the guy this one uh like
eight times he burns a different broad
huh girls would go Jesus Christ move and
every time the guy nod
I'd push abroad they get some back to
get this went on with the warm-up act
like there then we had a wait for
Aerosmith to set up and we started doing
it again I started pushing the guy again
finally out one of those nods he just
fell power people started stepping on
them I mean they were like Jersey girl
there was that Banali he never said stop
pushing me nothing he didn't even know
he would try didn't know the [ __ ] one
dog he would fall asleep and get into a
crouched position like that I would just
bump in code like nothing happened he
would fall over and burn the girl with
the cigarette yeah and then the girl
would sway come up smack him he would
straighten up all right I won't smoke
two minutes later but I got it again and
me and my buddy would be eyeballing boy
so he nods we'd watch him nine push him
into the chick burn him this went on and
then finally he passed out people
started kicking my Aerosmith takes the
stage Steven Tyler is up there he's
[ __ ] Dodd mm-hmm he's skinny
you can see it was like she got dead dot
Wow
you knew they were done this has to be
79 he done and brother and ended up with
him getting punched in the face 20 times
and him running off stage only five and
that was it Aerosmith was done Wow
Aerosmith it was done I'm in Colorado
three is laying in a hotel with a
chicken I'm watching MTV mm-hmm and then
TV news goes up to Boston then they go
where the high school where rumors are
reported that Aerosmith is getting back
together again
yeah and they went through rehabs in the
raw and then he couldn't show them it's
show like them cutting through a glass
and trying to get a peak arrows been
rehearsing mm-hmm and you could hear
them well that was it they were Smith
released them called up with mirrors
that was hot garbage man garbage you
came out 85 maybe a hot garbage
they had a song that Joe Perry had
written called
it was the name of his album hoof dos it
was just a god-awful out and then run
DMC comes in fiction does walk this way
remember I'll get [ __ ] of life
resurgence they ended up making more
money than what they did on the others
[ __ ] turnaround because now they knew
what they were doing that brought him
back that brought him back the big time
and right there well I'm watching Tyler
on Rogen I'm seeing this all this is
coming back to me going this is the
reason why yeah look at him he's 70
years old and he's a [ __ ] Savage yeah
he never gave up mmm-hmm and even when
they were talking about doing ayahuasca
and he goes I would never do it because
it's nice right good right that means
you're very you know who the [ __ ] you
are exactly takes you yeah I really find
that who the [ __ ] do you are going down
because unless Maxima and that dude
survived it man I mean he's been through
it all and he's still standing and I
think I mean he's sharper than ever
right now you know he's more coherent
and more on top of it than he was back
in the day did because he they went
through some [ __ ] up times yesterday
where they were just I mean I've seen
that firsthand with a lot of my friends
and it's not pretty
you know it's not it's not pretty to
watch that and to see somebody talented
who is just on the brink of just [ __ ]
completely losing everything and he
dropped and they life never really
mm-hmm
no alcohol never smoked never drank
never done any drugs aside from when I'm
in the hospital but that's about it
you happy variation yeah yeah and it's I
mean you know I I don't I don't you know
look down on anyone for doing anything I
don't judge anyone for anything it just
worked for me and there's no real reason
behind it other than I was just never
curious about it that's like really the
reason momdad drugs no they know I mean
my dad would would have a few beers a
year they didn't smoke they didn't do
any drugs so I never really saw that but
I mean you know
growing up in a with Mexican you know
relatives I mean on my uncle's I mean
typical you know Mexican family just
uncle's always hammered and and you know
was I
something might grew up with and saw but
it never it just never interested me I
was honestly too focused on music from
the time I was six years old that's when
I realized this is what I was gonna do I
honestly had just tunnel vision and I
didn't I saw what it was doing to some
of my friends who just didn't have any
control and we're just going off the
deep end and it kind of like made me
think [ __ ] you know if I do that I'm
gonna end up like that and I'm gonna
lose focus on what I'm here to do and I
mean I knew at an early age that this is
what you know I was gonna try to do how
when you knew music was six six
you knew I knew when I heard kiss alive
that was it man that was the record that
did it for me
at that point I was like when I heard
kiss alive I honest I remember telling
my cousin who was five years older than
me who played it for me I remember
telling him this that's what I'm gonna
do like this is what I'm gonna do and
that was honestly I mean the my aunt has
been my only focus since then so that's
a that's a big part of why I guess I
didn't do anything cuz I honestly felt
like if I do that I'm gonna I'm just
gonna have no control and just you know
end up going off the deep end what was
the first instrument you picked that
guitar it I was like 10 and then what
did you move on to always stayed on the
guitar but I mean I thought you play the
bass and yeah I taught myself how to
play the bass I play some drums I taught
myself keyboards I played the saxophone
all through junior high in high school
and I was [ __ ] did I was in the
marching band and I was in the [ __ ] I
was like a total band geek in school and
so I played the sax for six years and
and [ __ ] like that and but the guitar
has always been my main instrument you
know I read an article after you were on
the show the first time I hate when
somebody comes on the show and I find
out so much more about the man
there was an article you did an
interview your writing process like I
didn't know you were grabbing nominated
all this [ __ ] you know there was just so
many little things I didn't know about
it I felt ashamed yeah man but once I
got to see you like on the mandolin and
all that stuff that you know whatever
your [ __ ] they're gonna shut pick it
all up dude yeah it's just you're an
interesting [ __ ] you know man
nobody's interesting anymore like people
if they are interesting they're faking
the funk to me no you know people think
they're interesting when they talk
politics and they show you how smart
they are right you could tell how
[ __ ] ignorant they are you knew you
like this is what you want to talk about
yeah it's on the news every night from
6:00 to 648 exactly I need this [ __ ] in
my life from you you know so it's weird
when somebody's genuinely interesting
from the heart that you go [ __ ] send us
that yeah I appreciate the other one I
love when I find little [ __ ] not about
people like now all right Stephen Tao
when you see a guy like Stephen Tyler
yeah you look at the other guy pirate of
the Caribbean yes Johnny Depp and he's a
[ __ ] faking the funk right a [ __ ]
up totally like if you can't hide by
seeing that right you see you know like
that's the first person I thought of
because I've seen him walking around
it's a big you know he's been living in
this fantasy Johnny yeah for 25 it's
almost yea it's almost dude when I see
people like that and not just him but
like other people it's almost like
they're putting on a costume yes yes he
and they want to like play that role and
you can see the difference I mean that's
a great comparison there between Stephen
and him you see Steve you get the sense
that Stephen that's no outfit that's no
costume that is that's who he is and
then you see other guys like that and
you're like yeah you know that that guy
was like okay what am I gonna wear today
what am I gonna put on to try to make
people think I'm this or you know give
them that perception that I'm you know a
certain way when truly they're not it
was a Hollywood party by mistake and
you're in this six minutes I have and
you're asking yourself what the [ __ ] a
bug yeah like I have indeed I
for me first I asked myself that
question but then it's the second
question you know what that question is
maybe it's not even the question the
statement that comes out of my brain is
maybe it's you that's [ __ ] up so how I
turn into Liam to animals I stand there
with my foot on the wall I have [ __ ]
going through an anxiety attack asking
myself why I'm not like these people
right how come I couldn't wear an orange
shirt and put grease in my hair right
and come down here with an entrance and
make believe I'm somebody I'm not I'm
right why can I do that I went like I
said I went through this I'm dying up
here put me in a few episodes and they
invited me to like this party mmm they
write me to a wrap party and stuff I was
out of town you know and somebody put
you in a few episodes Jesus Christ
kaliesha give this show up wave it they
had little finger food and I can bring a
guest ice let me take my wife out of the
date it's a Monday night I kill two
birds one stone
number two stopping a Cuban food all
right because the thing is in Hollywood
right so we'll kill that [ __ ] need to
get some black beans and rice and I do
it right and then we go to a party if
the food sucks you're not sitting there
going on the red sox you know the food
was on the side a [ __ ] geeky [ __ ]
white people in hollywood think they
gotta give you you know mango wrapped
right you know the waffle whatever well
that was the cheeseburgers where's the
[ __ ] steak ala mode where's the
[ __ ] you know but you get there and
they have some completely different you
know right we have what's the new thing
those french fries they give you travel
fries no the other ones that did the
discrete potatoes if you come be with a
sweet potato french fry we're gonna have
a [ __ ] problem all right
don't bring a sweet but the one thing I
agree with you honor well that pizza
that were bad but right away we have go
Goku's pizza why can't it just be
regular without pizza yeah give me the
one with the regular cheese no we don't
have it then they bought a wings was how
we'll eat out no more
no cuz it just nasty now make something
like pigeon wings or something yeah
they're like pigeon wings
you know you're gonna either win go to
Buffalo take the [ __ ] with the note
attached yeah I'm there yeah then you
bro I saw something out there that was
creepy as [ __ ]
I saw them finally washed a grill at
7-eleven yet that ice is grilled that
ice is thick hamburgers that poor little
Hindu is behind there holding his
eyeballs and [ __ ] those fumes from those
hot dogs and I have those those things
kill you you only have dogs that are
good or the Oscar Mayer was right I
think they took out mmm and [ __ ] just
put regular Isis brought dogs now
stretch out of the Philippines they got
[ __ ] dog noodles and eyeballs Italy
[ __ ] they got everyday have them have
you looked in those little see-through
[ __ ] croquettas they have now I go
over to 7-eleven and stand on line just
to look at what's in there and just play
guess what's it that is the food guess
what's in that [ __ ] rap you could see
it's coming right through like if you
eat that you will [ __ ] take an
ambulance ride do you think that going
back to the the people who kind of fake
the funk do you think they go home and
there's someone different or do you
think they've just turn them when I go
home they [ __ ] cry I think so they go
home and cry you think giant Devas
crying they go home and cry some part of
their life has to be dark because they
really can't be they wanna be that's a
weird thing for some people having to go
home you know people who actually go out
there go hmm what can i attach myself to
maybe I write at Smyth to gay people
hang out with gay people and that looks
cool because I hang out with gay people
don't make me [ __ ] cool I read right
through it
now then there's the people one day go
you know what I think I'm going to
become a rocker if you know the rock in
high school you're never gonna be a
rocker I knew you were a rocker chick
when you were 16 there's a chicken on
Facebook I've been talking to a door you
know a daughter's aspiring so I've been
going back and forth with her she was a
rocker in high school now was she when
we were 16 she was sucking 18 19
year-old dick somebody who played the
bass in the band you know and I wasn't
mana ain't mad that she's getting
quality dicket [ __ ] v alone the guy in
the talent show
get into the [ __ ] bars and Emily
would yeah but still I'm not mad that's
what you do you're into bands but she's
a stoner
these chicks nowadays we're like you
know like when they had those concerts
now and the Desmond know what you know
what it is it's rich kids who go buy a
shirt they don't know nothing about the
band nothing nothing they never you know
big thing that happened last week was
they were talking about how your boy
Nine Inch Nails did something this year
for this tour mm-hmm he [ __ ] made
people go down and buy the tickets
physically and stand on line away from
the commit no [ __ ] online ticket
sales why because he wanted to bring it
back to the old school I like that I'm
like you know what bro that sounds like
a ballsy [ __ ] move that slows your
fans off but no it doesn't it makes your
real fans you know time and to you but
that you know that the tickets are still
now there dude they're there I'm sure
they're online and like they're already
you know Nine Inch Nails yeah yes so be
there it's different to stand on line
it's a lot easier if I tell you to be a
scalper and you have to just buy 20 um
I'm gonna stand down there and show you
how ace it's kind of creepy yeah so I
think in a way it's yeah I remember
that's what it was like back in the day
yeah like you had to go to the [ __ ]
box office I'm like I mean that's what
we did how old do you end up by 49 so
you I said oh dude I remember back in
the seventies dude that's what I used to
do man I still remember them send in a
check in a money order so you could wall
the four tickets yeah yeah let's
remember okay you could order four
tickets so ministry was playing and
Thursday Friday Saturday me you and Lee
would get together he would send them a
check for Thursday I tend to check for
Friday you send the check in for
Saturday we're partners on the deal yeah
we might get Thursday and Saturday which
will take yeah but at least we've got a
chance so now we definitely go god
forbid all three of us get together and
we go Thursday Friday Saturday yeah it
was to treat back then right so you had
the mail but then you also had standing
on line hmm Pink Floyd the war I went
right
fifteen dollars and fifty cents I can
ticket Rhonda you know the trunk was
talking about how you the guy would turn
around and go into a card file yeah and
show you what seats were right all right
I was like a goose bumps and Eddie trunk
was talking about oh my god I used to go
to this place called things from England
mmm it's still there cliffs I parked New
Jersey if you didn't want to go to the
garden he would have the tickets he
charged you a little big now ten bucks
for going into the city it was working
worth it yeah you went got me tickets
for ten bucks go yeah I'll pay the 20 no
no I can go over there Stan like an
animal pay the toll play hooky and get
caught yeah and get robbed and go to a
peep show but you know what [ __ ] it
maybe get blown yeah let's call it a
date I would never get blown in that
that age like I was trying to get my
dick sucked and 12:13 like everybody's
trying to get your dicks left we will go
to a little strip club right right off
of uh it was right in Manhattan right
off Broadway they didn't give a [ __ ] how
old you are back yeah yeah and I
remember them calling us in and you
could sit on the girls lap and our job
was to just feel him up as much as we
could so the tab came I didn't it
because the girls thought we would go
did you buy me a drink and while you're
waiting for the drink you feel their
tits you're like 13 you're like a
barracuda you got hands all over them
you're like Cosby turns 18
you're like Cosby with Harvey and the
girls never said like hey that's not
touching my tears nothing that you're
grabbing that [ __ ] then the drink comes
in it's like $40 you ain't got 40 hours
hey get the [ __ ] out of here you just
felt her up finger I get in really
finger you fingered it through the jeans
and when you're 13 that's that's good
enough that's enough it I wouldn't wash
my hands for two three days if I put my
hand between your crotch and I got some
of that [ __ ] juice at a strip club what
a disgusting
these women were disgusting disgusting I
was no [ __ ] prize cats either I was
13 with a half a bozo hairdo on my dick
the top was empty but the sides were
full once a second 13-year old dick
nobody was just like a 13 year update 14
maybe once you get that hair
you know those schoolteachers to suck
your dick for fun
baby silver I never got a babysitter's
suck my dick one time when I was like
six
I had a Puerto Rican baby so that I
asked her to suck my dick she told me
she'd suck my dick
and six oh my god I wasn't took a shower
and everything I hated showers when I
was six hey Peyton I'm getting ready for
oh I put Kyle hold on I put the gold
Rayna
hits it puts him under we're on our back
Kyle's your good underwear in a row my
name was DITA and she was Porto Rican Oh
[ __ ] she went back in the room and
blew on my stomach but I gave him like a
bag full of change she told me for the
small 20 shoots like my dick really so I
gave her like a bag full of that you
didn't pay for [ __ ] in point yes I
did and she took it and she told me that
was it I'm like listen though you know
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you and that
morning I face my whole life for that so
this [ __ ] day I think of whatever I
think about this it's what I'm gonna
playground with my daughter
look at that I must have been it must
have been six six and that damn
and I'm like waking my mom up that
morning mama had talked to my mom
putting on the sandals you know hungover
all right poor Donora hungover as [ __ ]
no she just walked in at 3:30 the bar
closes at 3:00 right people living in
New York City she's to get home but I
call it a fall for that and I would wake
her up like it's 7:30 didn't make me
breakfast and go off on her but whatever
happened the night before with the
babysitter that poor woman I'll never
forget her making me like eggs or
something I don't know what she would
make for breakfast in those days that
would eat and me look at her go unless I
got talked about so and she said get my
solo list I give teeth it 20 bucks last
night I got my opinion you know I was
trying to tell her in English right to
loosen the paint all right and I didn't
really know that much English like mom I
gave teether 20 bucks to give me a blow
job you know just suck my dick and my
mom can like hypnotize you told you get
to Italian girl like what are you
talking about I'm like mom you ain't the
best for me mmm all my opinion and
all up in my mom's like are you [ __ ]
crazy like it's eight and you're talking
about kicking you dick
you were six years old I'm like that's
the point she told me she was gonna suck
right now I'm going off in Spanish yeah
my mother's like you're not saying this
to me I had the [ __ ] 7:30 in the
morning that this poor baby said it and
then she woke her up
I did that but what's he saying and
she's like he asked me for a [ __ ] and
I told him I took his money that's not
the way they talk to a lady and my mom's
like I agree and I'm like [ __ ] that I'll
kill her I [ __ ] fell asleep and there
was scared of me like at that time my
mom knew I was doing my dad had died I
was uh I got hit there with a flashlight
and a lunch box I was going off the
[ __ ] well he's taking karate and [ __ ]
so my mom do I was serious I know if you
don't give me the 20 oz right now
[ __ ] stab it tomorrow night you know
what I'm gonna give you the 20 don't
talk to her no more just stay the [ __ ]
away from I didn't talk to that [ __ ]
like a year don't allow them took my 20
yeah
damn oh yeah anything like that ever
happen to you Lee no no I I can't I like
where we gonna get a knife when you talk
I'm like on top of the table with a good
knife like a mother that's been yellow
that from the top of my lungs she better
get my [ __ ] money I'm gonna [ __ ]
cut her in all this [ __ ] and my mom said
like a straight razors on the saddle no
whoo no oh no what the [ __ ] was going on
you know who the [ __ ] knew and then when
I was about 14
no that was about 13 she was still my
stepfather she brought a chick home for
me one day when I was about 13 to the
eighth grade they brought a woman home
one night yeah me I was a moment when
Constance having my bar mitzvah at 13
and I'm downstairs and also the guys are
down there from the barn I'm gonna go go
wash up put like a suit off it's just us
Thank You dick and I'm like come on
really
yeah your mother brought a home for you
to suck your dick so I went upstairs and
took my pajamas off you think our will
suit on you know I ain't back like
[ __ ] Piett god damn I started dancing
with her
well I touched a [ __ ] the first time we
got like dizzy dog yeah like I got
you're still wearing pajamas
dip so this dad I'm aloof I [ __ ] her
if I passed out I think I just passed
out from the anxiety did that first time
that that happens to it it's like hey
your head yeah it was terrible it was
terrible
like you don't know what could happen
how are you the first time you fell in
love like fell in love heartbroken that
you still remember that bitch's name
today Oh have you been doing the share
of those gallery you might hit her in
the heck does she [ __ ] your [ __ ] up for
two years issue um I was probably well
nineteen maybe as she broke your heart
yeah how'd she break you her I mean it
was just the typical you know breakup
kind of thing and and she ended up like
she was you know with someone else
behind my back kind of thing and I found
out about it or yeah it's because I was
the first one you know I mean that was
like really like that and so I mean
that's really it wasn't a huge thing but
for me back then when it's the first
chick that you're really in love with
and you find that can you know you find
out that kind of [ __ ] it's it's pretty
[ __ ] you know traumatic at that age
and you're like fog every day I just
want to die and like every teen sucks
and you know it just [ __ ] up did and
um there's gonna be I broke my heart
when I was about twelve she just [ __ ]
me up I got left back I got five stopped
going to karate really and she wasn't
even here's the dumb thing like I felt
till this day I still feel bad talking
about it because I was such an [ __ ]
like I deserved it like I bought into
Love & Roses I join her and a
grandmother to a movie who does that
like two or three times I don't take the
grandmother to the movie Wow if I knew
what I do today I would have [ __ ]
stand Imbaba grandma suck my dick why
would a finger the grandmother at the
movie think I'm crazy
while you watch Caligula yeah I don't
think the [ __ ] you know put it take four
hours and then chopping up my ax I'm
trying to fill up your granddaughter
here and you're over you're playing
[ __ ] rock or the cobbler about
usually how old were you I was young I
was like maybe six and out we didn't
even Dow is so mixed em I don't know no
like sixth grade
six six seventh grade she was like not
my neighbor but pretty much you know how
long have you been asking me to take
walks Joey we would take walks every
[ __ ] day with our dogs
I touched her boobs but I was I was way
too scared to do anything with her and
then years later she said she had a
crush on me too but and of course
looking back I should have tried to kiss
or something but I was just so what like
12:30 something like that yeah she she
gave me a lap dance once how old you
when she gave me a lap dance
this was the lap dance I had a front
door Sept up and I laid down on my front
on the floor of my house and she just
like kind of like grind on there for
like two seconds I don't know she moved
away like in high school so maybe 13 14
like that was it though like that it was
like two seconds he didn't take anything
off it was it was in the middle of
[ __ ] day I just had trees around my
house but she was hot
[ __ ] that's more accident I didn't get
any no I had no [ __ ] ass I didn't
kiss her I didn't do anything I just she
just for more action that I [ __ ] had
it I didn't have any I didn't I didn't
get any until I was 17 I didn't have
which was late in nineteen twenty like
late compared to like my friends and
[ __ ] like that who were all like they'd
already gotten you know late at 14 15
you know I don't count that [ __ ] I was
like that disgusting [ __ ] I don't count
my police records I wasn't talking about
that because like what was the first
time you got laid that you were in love
that's when it counts for me then I
would stick me to a hooker house one
time yeah it was disgusting yeah you
know yeah you got your dick sucked but
it was under fucked-up circumstances she
was half asleep on a quaalude something
I'm saying that was always some bill was
in the room yeah something's was going
on like I got caught fingering this girl
what I'm thinking of the front yard the
father goes you gotta come in and he's
like now and my hands down I'll [ __ ]
hands on the farm our luck I was finger
than outside smoke was coming he's like
ten degrees yeah and you can see a [ __ ]
head like he caught fire as I was finger
there like a [ __ ] snow machine that
was a sewing machine we live in the sole
Machine neighborhood and you will hear
those sewing machines going off and I go
Jesus Christ I want to [ __ ] some
with that intensity with that rhythm
with that [ __ ] rhythm I had her I was
looking eighth grade and I had her out
there they were German and they hated
[ __ ] enough the Father but the brother
will [ __ ] not they hated [ __ ]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] the Father but the
brother was saying to me [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you know yeah damn but when I
fingered his sister he lost all face
like even now he won't friend me on
Facebook because how's it feel
I was finger banging your sister that
this [ __ ] you weren't talking much about
specs back then and [ __ ] you sent him a
little video machine yeah yeah that's
why I've you're racist you better I have
a sister
yeah I was late man I felt for me it
felt like losing yeah for a while how
old did you say you were I was in
college my first year of college or so
yeah or no it was my second year of
college
oh you finger the wolf oh I don't even
work to be honest I don't I don't really
remember and my it wasn't I did that
before I was probably 18 maybe sometime
in college I didn't do it I had sex I
didn't do anything ever really sucked my
dick like I hadn't had sex and I was old
already
like tonight what I messed around with
Gina I was 16 and 15 or 16 but we didn't
do nothing we just stuck in a hole and I
moved it around I shot a load yeah he
was bleeding a little bit
I didn't think anyone's virginity but it
was crazy that after I got my heart
broken that time I became a piece of
[ __ ] you know like two or three years I
was just banging chicks virgins now then
I would call him up and they break up
with them on the phone and I was cold
blooded I dated two girls that were
crying on the phone and I'm like I'm
mundane you know ma what's that must at
that hundred I would said it like that
to go it is terrible
I think I remember the first time I
fingers I think I might have an eighteen
seventeen eighty I met her on Craigslist
I forgot about that
and we dated I actually dated someone
from Craigslist we should pick me up
from the train I was in college
oh my god and and she was like I'm not
gonna come home with you but I'll give
you a [ __ ] and you can finger me so
that was I was yeah I was 18 Jesus
Christ
women so you you
met her on craig's oh yeah and by like I
was nerdy as [ __ ] I was you know but
like what you were like looking for for
a girl from the effort for not even like
hooking up to be honest I was just so
shy that I was before online dating
really Wow
so yeah we didn't have that back in the
day man yeah we did it all so no it's
nothing like that did it was like oh I
heard so-and-so is like doing so and so
so you might want to owe everyone else
knows that Twitter I wasn't doing a key
I was so [ __ ] shy I know what happens
when I know exactly what happened like I
fooled around and I got taken to a hook
house and after that I was very careful
and very like selective as [ __ ] like
that that I had worked as a doorman at a
massage parlor for Louise Donato one
summer and he got me like a [ __ ] and
some crazy chick that's still I don't
count it because you know what man it
wasn't really somebody who cared about
you you kidding about them it's so weird
and then I fell in love with a girl I
mean sex with and it was weird that I
was in love but we had the sex and after
that we didn't see eye to eye
hmm like we were in love for four years
we had sex and that was it that just one
that changed my outlook yeah well we had
sex like two nights and that changed my
outlook on after that I was 20 19 I was
heading out there no I knew the game all
right there's no way you could start
changed yeah it was weird
now it was very weird how it came and
went and how you reacted mm-hmm but
after those two relationships I was
that's it I was done with in my mind
yeah I thought I knew how to treat women
and the whole [ __ ] deal and I was
still not ready knows I think I got
married at 25 eighty-nine order 89 days
I was 26 when I got married and I was
there already for Mary smiles no [ __ ]
way yeah
were you ever married never anybody come
close mmm I was proposed to once but it
didn't obviously didn't work out like it
was
Jesus this was probably like 20 years
ago maybe I was probably like around
your age did oh yeah yeah yeah traveling
of the road I was I was in local I was
in regional bands like I was being I was
in bands it was that you know we would
tour like you know in the states like
the southern states or up north and [ __ ]
like that right now music yeah yeah but
it was before like my first record deal
so it was I was on the verge of getting
signed with my first deal and this
particular girl had never dated someone
in a band and she was extremely jealous
and and I you know I was I was not
definitely not ready for it at the time
either and we were just date I think we
had been dating for like a year or
something like that and and she just
like one night proposed to me like
[ __ ] ring in the hole bit and I was
like [ __ ] like like we just got out to
dinner man and we went back to her place
and she just broke that out and I was
like [ __ ] I was not expecting that and
so I told her I had to think about it
which is basically no and it wouldn't
have worked out anyway scuzz we were
just two different people and and you
know she was just like if if she just
saw girls around me she was already like
blown up and human and [ __ ] like that
and it's tough you know in this business
and and and being that age and you know
just getting my career started remember
you're heard of someone getting proposed
to before that's the coolest thing I've
ever heard 12 years ago 2006 Wow
and you write a lot of [ __ ] I read -
yeah yeah a lot of thank God yeah I
heard him ombre and he was interesting -
oh yeah did bill came to our rehearsal
number when when was that
a few months ago yeah three four months
ago we were rehearsing here and
North Hollywood and Bill came down
because Al had done his his show and he
got behind your kit Denis for a little
bit mmm no but at rehearsal he was like
he was kind of behind your kit and [ __ ]
like that but yeah I mean when I first
came on board with ministry he flew me
out to Texas cuz he was living in El
Paso at the time and that's where he had
a studio and he was just like yeah I
want you to help me you know write the
new record and I didn't know I've never
written with him before so I didn't know
how much writing I was gonna get in and
like the first day I showed him one of
my riffs and he's like yeah that's you
know it's cold call me when it's done
and he leaves the studio and it's just
me in this engineer who I just met and I
basically like recorded all the music to
this one song I did all the guitars I
did the bass I did some of the keyboards
and like two or three days later he came
back and he's like let me hear what you
got and so he heard it and he's like
awesome he's like what else you have so
I played him another idea and he's like
cool call me when it's ready and he
leaves again and so I ended up like
writing half of that album like the
music - half of that record I played the
guitar in that entire record and so that
was like my my first record with him and
I thought I was just gonna write that
that record but as soon as I finished
that one he was like I want you to do
this cover cover-up record and so I
stayed another like month and I did that
one and then I did a revolting [ __ ]
record with him as well and that
cover-up record is is the one that got
me my first Grammy nomination and that
was [ __ ] 12 years ago dude I did like
three records in a row out in Texas and
and then we started rehearsing and we
went on tour and I mean I've been with
them ever said I don't even know how
many records I've done with them now
probably like five or six or something
like that
and you have to take your writer so what
you put your head to that solvent know
exactly where you going it it it always
varies sometimes it's already written in
my head and I literally just pick up a
guitar or something and it just kind of
comes out
and then other times I have a general
idea but I have to kind of work on it
and it could take like weeks you know
but usually like say today if I if I
decide I want to write a song I could
probably have something written by the
end of the night whether it's a little
good or not lyrics no I just do music
yeah I only do music just to leave yeah
al does all all the lyrics and shifts
and that's and that's been the case with
all my bands I've always just done the
music so you can do music without
knowing what the songs like so yeah they
based like the energy of the song off of
whatever you just did and then the
lyrics do it correct
oh very which is well some some writers
do lyrics and then do the music
according to that but in all the bands
that I've ever been in it's always been
music first and then you know like the
singer the lyricist will get what he
usually have lyrics kind of set in mind
and he'll be like oh okay this should go
well with this type of music and [ __ ]
like that
great yeah but I mean it's been like
that I've been writing songs since I was
10 11 years old
what's your I mean it's some people
don't like this question but what's your
favorite part do you like writing
playing drawing like what's your
favorite thing to do before it's tough
to answer writing writing gives me a
different high but it's between writing
and performing not so much touring but
actually being on stage and performing
really yeah it's those two things
writing gives me just as much of a high
as performing does but it's different
it's a different kind of I because like
when you're performing like you've got
you know the crowd right in front of you
and they're giving you that energy when
you're writing I mean it's just you but
it's it's a different high that you get
you know when you when you realize that
you're creating something and that
literally like you start out with a
blank slate and it's for me at least
it's really exciting to just feel that
that energy coming through me that I'm
writing I'm creating something and I
know that in a few hours I will have
this kind of thing that I've created
from nothing and so that's you
bully as much of a high as performing I
think was the last time we came what was
it that we watched that documentary on
Netflix about and I forget the time gun
hired gun our guns hired guns so indeed
if you were a hired gun you'd feel like
you'd like it but there'd be a piece
missing but I miss writing like it's not
enough just to play I mean I I don't
know that I would feel something's
missing because you're still playing
which is something that I mean that's
you love to do so I mean I've been a
hired guy many times and I don't feel
like anything's missing
I just love writing you know a lot and
not everybody writes you know everybody
people there are guys out there that
just play they're just in bands and they
just play their instrument and you know
okay here's the music learn this and
that's great you know that's fine I mean
those guys are still feeling that high
because that they love playing and [ __ ]
but for me it's like it's everything
that's involved from the from the you
know starting point of and having
nothing to seeing it you know the end
result you know onstage in front of like
[ __ ] fifty thousand people it's like
it's a trip to be up there sometimes
when we're playing something that I
wrote at home with my acoustic guitar
that you know like eight months a year
you know before that there was nothing
and now you know all these people are
like [ __ ] pumping their fists and
singing back stuff that you know we we
wrote so it's it's pretty [ __ ] cold
man
I mean it's a huge hi you're such a
beautiful you highlight to watch you
play guitar on stage I mean I've seen a
lot of guitar players they just I feel
it with you you're into it you you know
the big thing around here is when you
commit the universe takes care yeah and
you know like I've watched movies and
had friends and good in bands that have
been cover bands hmm and obviously the
breakout you have to write your own
original material sir but when you're
playing but keep see New York and a
Friday night they don't give a [ __ ]
about sins and use it we have a gif
don't really give a [ __ ] about this is
about a girl I'm I was having a mocha
hey Hollywood last summer you know this
little song for you a little ditty for
you people get pissed yeah they cut back
from that show like I went to see Sam
Tammy talked to my political [ __ ] whole
[ __ ] time he didn't play black voodoo
woman oh but I you know like magic woman
you know so it's such a [ __ ] again if
you were comment you want to just
perform what I did for 10 years there's
a stage for that
yeah and you could write on the run and
take chances on the stage there's a
market for that yeah but to get to the
upper level just like in music they want
to know what's in your heart
well show our mind and how you stand
with it what you know okay you told us
that joke is dirty but why do you feel
that way right now right what's funny
I'm a week away from taping a Netflix
special is that the one with you doing
it yeah Vegas baby
28 minutes you know I've had that power
for a year and I said this is not what
I'm using this is what I'm using I get
onstage next Monday at 7:00 I just want
to tell you people that I got 20 minutes
I still got eight minutes that I'm
missing mm-hmm because I don't give a
[ __ ]
sure like I don't give a [ __ ] yeah it's
gonna work because you commit to the
universe of course in the University and
every day my wife got me an iPad for
Christmas is the first time have you
written on an iPad completely different
ballgame like now I could move [ __ ] no I
see there's no bright I got one page for
that a particular bit now you see the
bit so it's like flashcards Wow
so it's a different experience I've been
doing comedy for 27 years and you're
still learning something sure so when I
saw all this big stuff about you writing
I was like that energy for years I could
write a joke onstage
yeah thank heaven pray that Lee's dad
taping it orally which goes eight don't
forget that joke about [ __ ] the bunny
and lightning I'm fine it was great
whatever you know most the time I I
throw away more good jokes the Brea
comics right on stage yeah just going up
there hi just talking I you know I could
go on now I could do it every night I
just don't want to do it because you
paid 25 bucks right I don't want to take
that chance tonight follow me so it's
just really weird
the energy you get from writing mm-hmm I
didn't even know any
existed till I read the Stephen King
book I'm writing
mm-hmm and he broke it down about the
energy that you get that's what I really
got into it
sure and I wrote a few things for the
book you know that aren't any [ __ ]
good but I still felt that energy going
through my veins yes I was writing it
which yes there's something there I'm
not looking at it the right way and so
what that means because once you feel
that energy you're in the right [ __ ]
direction definitely music has always
destroyed me
all right that's why I tip my hat no I
feel that anybody could write a good
joke music is the one that as you're
writing and I look at you and the studio
and go this is gonna be on the rage yeah
I mean it's I feel the same with with
writers or guys that do lyrics or write
you know jokes scripts stuff like that
that to me is like [ __ ] those guys have
a gift to me like writing music I'm like
anybody can do that that's how I see it
so it's a it's a different thing that I
wish I had I wish I had really gone into
more of the the lyrical part of writing
as opposed to just music but music I
mean it that's where it took me you know
clearly that seems to be where if you'd
call it a gift that's where it is for me
is is writing music because that seems
to come easy for me and natural more
than anything it's like it's it's a
natural thing for me to do it's not like
I'm ever like oh man I have to write
something and what am I gonna do it's
not like that uh it just happens and I
know that I totally understand what
you're saying where you know you're
missing eight minutes out of your act
but you know it's gonna I know it's that
I know it's the other day I totally
relate to that when when I have
something to do musically and I'm like
well [ __ ] I don't have X amount of time
to do this but I don't worry about it
because I know that it's just it's just
gonna happen I know it's there and I
know that when it's something that that
comes from the heart and it's something
that's that is you it just happens man
you know you don't have to like
[ __ ] worry about it and what am I
gonna do or [ __ ] like that because you
know it's it's just who you are and you
know that it's gonna show up you know
it's never failed me to this point you
know many times where I've been like I
have to have the song written or I have
to do this or whatever and it's not done
and I'm in the studio right now you know
in the [ __ ] clock's ticking but I
know that I'm gonna have something
written I know it's gonna come it's
never failed me if it fails you if you
don't do the work exactly if you do the
work of course well Little Wolf
of course yeah that's how I feel of
course we day I'm sitting myself down
and it's not forcing myself you know
it's not it's not about Albin going you
know what yeah now would it kill me the
coffee shop write and write this for an
hour which is that I mean I I agree with
you that I label that that's part of the
work process that's part of it you got
to do that let's do the Dada you what
you have to have you've got to put the
work and I didn't know about this till
five years ago I didn't know that I were
working when I read the war of art or
whatever the [ __ ] it is the art of war
whatever the [ __ ] it is it really opened
my eyes to what needs to be done every
day not what you want to do or what you
don't want to do right what needs right
to be done in a daily basis
for you to be that person to be that
guitarist ministry how much pressure
comes with that it can come with or
without pressure right the pressure is
if you just coexist right and go hang
out with Steven Adler alright and talk
about the G in our days then you're just
gonna be a sack of [ __ ] exact you hang
around with dönitz you become a [ __ ]
doughnut eventually but if you go to the
studio every day for two hours exactly
even if you just go in tune your guitars
play a couple licks and just take that
lick and play it and then your
girlfriend gorgeous is get home I made
pork chops and you go home that [ __ ]
wall our still a mess I agree I agree
that's what I didn't know for years I
didn't know that that one hour that's
why when I started learning about that
hour I utilize it because at first I was
doing the Comedy Hour a pen in your
mouth hmm
and then you flip the pen over and you
taste the coca did two months ago
through the [ __ ] big pen you know I'm
saying your mouth is numb now you're
trying to write you feel like a
Colombian farmer confuse
it's the afternoon and you got a coke
blush in your [ __ ] mouth and now you
gotta write a [ __ ] joke or something
and you don't write dick
forty minutes goes by and you go you
know what I'm getting the [ __ ] out I'm
gonna cop a bag of dope own a look at
this they do once I started sitting down
and just going okay we don't have a joke
to right let's try the story of the time
me and Cyn went to Bakersfield him we
got a flat on there or a five you'll
think of it you're right and while
you're writing it you go oh my god
there's a joke right the something's
here boom there you go yeah and now I
transform it into my act and now you
didn't waste them out right you didn't
waste an hour
no you have a page that you're just
gonna run so does that clock starts boom
you start writing your story I totally
totally don't worry about the comments
don't worry about the pronunciation you
don't need to spell it nobody's a
spelling bee just so you write it and
then you look at it put the correction
and then rewrite it now before you
rewrite it you'll think of a joke or
promise mm-hmm
I promise you because your exercise my
mind right it's the same [ __ ] thing
I agree that for me it's like every day
even if I just [ __ ] grab my guitar
and just strum a few chords
tune it whatever it I mean some nights
you know I try to write as much as I
possibly can just because it's it's it's
always there and I always try to just
document I record you know a riff that I
have in my head I just record it and
that could be it that could be all the
work I do that day with music but I know
that within that riff I'm gonna go back
to it and I'm gonna hear something you
know just a part of it that will now
trigger a song or trigger a different
idea but I think it's it's very
important that you do that and you touch
on that every day if you can if you're
if you're if you are a guitar player
pick up your guitar and just [ __ ]
play a little bit you know [ __ ] if
you feel inspired enough to write
something write something if you if
you're not feeling the inspiration of a
song at least just [ __ ] grab your
instrument just [ __ ] play it just do
something because I think you
it for for my experience that keeps that
flowing and it keeps that energy going I
could never like completely walk away
from the guitar and not touch it for
weeks and [ __ ] like that like I couldn't
do that like I don't think any of us
could could do that any of the guys and
you know in what we do even want to come
to drums the same thing you got to get
on them every day play and put a little
jam on play over it a little bit yeah
it's just I mean I think it's it's I
think it's like it's in our DNA and I
think it's something that that we just
it's in our blood
and it's a natural thing for us it's not
anything that we look at like you said
like oh it's a chore it's it's even
though I call it work I don't look at it
like you know what I mean it's something
that I'm dreading that I have to do now
that's like we never look at it like
that you know and yeah exactly
yeah and then I mean the with me with
writing it's like I could be driving
home after this and hear some noise
outside somewhere you know a car making
a weird sound or whatever and that will
trigger something in me that'll stay in
my head and I will go home and just riff
something out either on the bass or on
the guitar or I'll program something on
the drums because if it's a rhythm that
I heard or something like that because
I'll use whatever the [ __ ] I have to to
start an idea it doesn't always just
because I'm a guitar boat doesn't mean
it always starts on the guitar I've
written songs entirely on bass I've
written songs I've started songs with
just a drum beat or a drum pattern and
so it can be triggered by anything you
know and it thank God it seems to flow
and it hasn't stopped yet so I'm hanging
in there hoping it doesn't stop and he's
right now I write the Bible like a bio
for calmly yeah who sent the comedy
clubs I'm writing a bio I'm trying to
write the book a chapter and I'm trying
to write stand-up and I'm also science I
write my next special nice mentality
every day I apply the something so write
jokes every day yeah but every day to
get to the jokes I go through one of
those things you put in the work and
always catches
it always so you're here now and a half
go do something guess what if I do that
in the morning I'll still again at seven
and something else will come sure that's
actually the next couple weeks in the
next week yeah you know well I'm looking
for eight minutes
it's a man I got eight minutes I can
throw a piece of junk in there and right
make it new right it's not that it's I
want to be able to really see a pounding
I really want to see a pounding where's
Tony better that [ __ ] let me give
some shoutouts that my man Matt Moore a
fern x95 jack Geoffrey my Mandy in
Colorado
Cletus Augustus the valve colonel
Cecelia tea snack and Danny be sports
for all your sports information go to
Danny be sports tell him uncle Joey sent
you let me ask you this cuz you're like
him 22 [ __ ] different bands which is
great I love it because I was looking
like that that's another thing I want to
talk to you about so sometimes you're
right in the zone at the end you see the
finished product you like [ __ ] out I'm
not giving out this masterpiece I say
that all the time I'm going to this guy
yeah [ __ ] out let out come up with his
own get them get a ukulele and stay up
all night
go buy a $10 bag of meth and see how it
is to write this [ __ ] out [ __ ]
so it was you write a song do you feel
it's for somebody else or do me and
you're playing with that's the hard
thing
definitely that's whatever no that's
like for me sometimes I think of a
jungle I'm like that's a little bit too
much of a story for this [ __ ] chapter
in this joke yeah right now I'm seeing
like you taped the Ice House for me I
don't get rid of those jokes that's too
long for the punchline okay we got a
half hour we'll kill it by slides eight
a minute now there's a that it's like
[ __ ] you know you're a [ __ ] sewing
machine but whatever what happens has it
changed
listening to music for you cuz now that
I get sometimes I can't really watch
specials because in my ologist start
writing and I'll have to turn the
special off cuz I have to write the idea
down and then I'm done do you what it's
changed for me in that usually when I
listen to stuff now I dissect everything
right
I hear that like okay I hear what this
instruments doing I hear what this is it
like it's almost like you're tearing it
apart that's what it's like for me and I
have to actually try to turn that off
when I'm listening to music so I can
just try to enjoy write a song because
for me that's what that's what ended up
happening is the more I wrote the more I
dissected stuff that I would just hear
like on the radio or an album or
something like that so that's how it
changed for me and I have to like really
try to not do that like I have to make a
conscious effort to not do that so I can
hear it as a whole you know you know
it's right you can actually I love
watching specials and there's only been
like a couple or less I've tried to
watch a bunch in the last few weeks and
if I had to turn them off you know
either I don't like them as much anymore
or I just think of [ __ ] right oh the
smoke you see the sky now so now you see
that you look behind the curtain oh so
now it's completely different you know
it's like they say you don't want to
really meet your heroes right you know
it's the same [ __ ] thing
once you see behind the curtain it's
tough to watch [ __ ] economy anymore
unless you watch a [ __ ] live like
when I go to the economy store early and
I sit there like when I was talking
about the fourth wall last night sitting
in the back and getting enamored by
comedy is a great thing guess what
and I'm doing especially and telling you
this than a special doesn't capture of
economic it really does it and they
don't know what they're doing they tell
you they know what they don't but they
don't know that they're dead oh look at
the [ __ ] videos of the 50s with Lenny
Bruce and look at the specials today I
get more of those videos of money Bruce
I just don't know how to shoot that way
mmm I don't know what they were shooting
or how they were shooting it they shot
from the waist up they kept the camera
on that you didn't minute move now they
want to show the audience the right the
smoke the people it's too much it's
become too much of an artistic thing
just shoot the [ __ ] comic know and
learn how to get the maximum laughter
out of it they don't hmm they don't so
that's why when I see a special on my
house yeah I have a good time for 10
minutes and then you see rocket and I
there's never you'll never hear me on
this podcast telling your special socks
on that
because I feel the same way about all
the comic is being funny is his [ __ ]
patois coming through that lens that
[ __ ] really real it really does
matter [ __ ] really like being in with
a crowd so when I go to the original
woman I said Mitzi's wrong I sit back
then I watch Burr and Ron white and
tally Wang and Chris D'Elia and brenards
Steve Simone I'm sitting back then
getting that full essence you know going
Wow
now I got without in the sea of a
special right he said that joke and the
special it sucked this is great try live
you get it live you start getting it
yeah on video I hate all of them I'm not
gonna lie didn't tell you they're all
[ __ ] great
I've seen some [ __ ] garbage the last
10 years but not the comic they've made
them garbage because they take that
focus off the comic mm-hmm Wow can you
believe there's no more live music well
we were coming up it was cheap track
live at Budokan the song remains the
same mm-hmm there was one other one no
UFO your folks in the night kiss did a
bunch of them yeah who else did one that
was really [ __ ] good not good so
you're really a kiss influenced big-time
big-time Ace Frehley Jason Ace Frehley
man yeah [ __ ] yeah that was like that
was like my first guitar hero was ace
frehley yeah and he deserves every bit
of that merit I think yeah phenom I mean
he's [ __ ] he's such a I mean he's I
feel underrated for what he for what he
did you know he's not like a technical
player but that's not his style like his
he plays from the heart and it's [ __ ]
real you believe it
like you believe every he can hang on
one [ __ ] note and Bend the [ __ ] out
of it and it's it makes more of an
impact than a guy [ __ ] doing
you know arpeggios at [ __ ] a million
miles and this is all [ __ ] under the
airforce the exact early yeah I know if
he could redo that I know they would do
best to pieces and he's I mean he's out
there again
he's going out with Alice Cooper I think
in the next month or two but but he's
opening phallus he's opening for Alice
like his own like Ace Frehley band
opening for Alice and he still [ __ ]
slaying it out there man and he's sober
he's sober he's been yeah yeah yeah and
his playing is still fussing oh [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah I'm I loved his interviews
I've been trying to get out of the
podcast he's hilarious I think he's as
funny as they fear is the pieces falling
out awesome if you could get him he's
tough he doesn't want to leave Costa
Mesa I'm fine now I know you know I know
yeah I know that the one guy went down
and they recorded two songs yeah you
know I listen to all the kiss stuff and
like I said I had a friend who was a
kiss guy me and him weren't the kiss
that he died never knowing kiss albums
now so now after 30 years I've let
myself to allow myself to listen to kiss
again
yeah hear different interviews on sirius
am yeah I get goose bumps too sure but I
remember how much I liked hey like I
remember the first time I heard I want
you I almost [ __ ] surd I almost like
I love all that schmuck yeah dude
and who's your second most influential
guitar player Oh Hendrix no [ __ ] yeah
third and be between [ __ ] either roads
or Trower Rob and Rob yeah yeah yeah I
mean if we're talking old school Trower
of the newer I would say Rhodes Randy
was young and all breach talks about
that guy from what's that bad they
haven't had will call Cricklewood green
love like a man I don't know what the
[ __ ] is that guy's name that played the
guitar they played Woodstock
[ __ ] um what's what you got love like a
man ten years after yes oh well so
what's the guitar players they have to
do yeah I remember the band something
green something else um thing something
ten years after
it's either Alvin Lee Alvin a little er
[ __ ] seasoned [ __ ] he's a monster
dog monster guitar player yeah I mean he
wasn't it wasn't the band was in a band
that I was no no no though that is into
yeah nobody but he's a [ __ ] mud
monster guitar player yeah no doubt
about that now was it you that was
telling me Randy Rhoads his mother was
done write down the error here's North
Hollywood
ya know Dolores [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah we went
to the same junior how you went to me
Audrina high which is the junior high I
went to in Burbank
I saw his mom a few times at her house
when she was still alive and yeah Randy
was a [ __ ] big influence did you know
when I was like 13 14 roads just [ __ ]
blew me away the [ __ ] he was doing was
just [ __ ] out there and you know to
this day I mean just listen to those
[ __ ] that first time every song did
every solo you remember it it's all
memorable it's [ __ ] the plane is
amazing my favorite solos I had goodbye
the Rope bastard classified in romance
to solo yesterday every time if I'm at a
light and I hear that it takes me right
back to whatever stupidity I was doing
that helmet came up takes me right back
did take you know I back what a [ __ ]
highlight was for me was about a year or
two ago I got to play there was a
because they do these Randy Rhoads
tribute shows like once a year and I got
to [ __ ] play suicide solution with
Rudy on bass that was [ __ ] killer for
me man to be able to do that Randy song
did you do it to the tee like hollering
yeah
the judge will play now I did I tried it
because it was a Randy thing so everyone
was there to hear Randy's solos like
Randy so I kept it pretty pretty Randy
ish and I mean did it was [ __ ] it was
a trip just being up there man and
looking over and there's [ __ ] and Rudy
impending away on the bass
there it would give him props to [ __ ]
Stephen tower before another guy that
you gotta give props to as crazy as he
now he's got his he does something on
Sirius where he interviews he doesn't
interview a read once a month with a
friend
mmm-hmm and as crazy as he is he still
[ __ ] ozzy osbourne yeah another guy
yeah that came from the [ __ ] trenches
of death was dead he was dead he was
dead guys he was above that liquor store
where the [ __ ] he was living [ __ ] dead
you know no hope and all sudden the
chick came by the manager yeah she told
the father told me was a sack of [ __ ]
yeah he was just a junkie she thought
different and it started cooperation
that's worth there's massive massive
massive and her dad was a big shot young
and big shot thief yeah he robbed those
guys he made them all into junkies every
time I just finished reading the the man
who led zepplin oh he worked for him
yeah yeah he works then that's how I
learned that was his first job he worked
for him and security up Wow doors they
brought same pan over and all those
[ __ ] bands from San Francisco that
[ __ ] but it's just really weird when you
look at even Ozzy Osbourne was dead no
dad they threw him out of his own
[ __ ] band like to go weak I'm gonna
[ __ ] out any way you'd done and then
they replaced him that guy sucked and
they replaced him with do the guy that
in between them this music online that's
just god-awful
that Lisa guy that came in was that Tony
the first guy that came in to sing was
god-awful AM to look up look up heaven
and hell with the [ __ ] if you go to
youtube okay I'll look up have it in
hell with the original singer you're
looking at porn over here yeah I have my
needs in heaven a skydiving coupon here
it'll say heaven in hell what the [ __ ]
is the guy's name Ralph something
it was god-awful alright so I have I
have
Ronnie James Dio don't mean Gillian Tony
Martin Glen here I was thinking about
Tony more my views right now tre Gillan
no Glenn Hughes was from deep purple
deep somebody came in right before
[ __ ] ramp Ronnie James Dio and they
taped they did a couple demos and they
said listen this sounds like somebody
died oh wait a minute yes yes yes yes
yes no it wasn't no I don't think it was
Glen know he was there someone's house
there was somebody else who came and I
found it I found him once there was
god-awful I think he was the wait I
don't see his name up there I Dave
Walker Dave Walker was the first singer
was it table yeah heaven in hell Dave
Walker listen to this diarrhea diarrhea
of a madman
listen to that the second would listen
to [ __ ] Julia's eyes with this
[ __ ] sappy [ __ ]
[Music]
and Sabbath was that to musically
they would that too
[Applause]
he was the first guy they brought it
[Applause]
Ozzie hates this [ __ ] out you can't
even bring this out around there he says
it's a [ __ ] jazzy band but listen for
this vocal diarrhea
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we don't
[Music]
I bet his maker
[Music]
you say Paterson
[Music]
horrible Wow I think they brought him in
and tried to squeeze Ozzy out and they
were gonna stay on tour and somebody
pulled him aside and said don't do it do
it all he's glad I was lucky that you
liked him because I can just imagine you
playing this outside of his house with
the boombox
if you don't like it all day God would I
heard that because I remember reading it
all we had then was cream magazine yeah
just circus and I'm a reading in a
circus that they were playing with Dave
Walker but something didn't work out and
then they didn't um do and even deal was
hard to swallow well that first drove to
Philadelphia I saw a deal on stage and
we'll started crying I almost started
crying and then I played that the hand
was pretty fun good yeah except for the
devil horns and [ __ ] he was okay but the
best thing about that concert was this
is how crazy life was lean it had to be
summer of 81 maybe and we drove down the
shore me this guy but I know I don't
know what the driver was but I know I
know this kid rest in pieces the guards
name is D'Andre go he was five foot two
steroid out he had to be a hundred
ninety pounds of pure muscle uh-huh
in those days I would make him take his
t-shirt off do push-ups I gotta get him
all jazzed up like do a couple lines of
coke give him a couple cocktails and I'd
say Darren take your shirt off do some
push-ups dog get ready for these
[ __ ] we could be anywhere they
wouldn't make him do push-ups like we're
going bar I haven't come in don't let
him blow do some [ __ ] push-ups and he
would do 200 push-ups um be yoked
fam and he'd walk in that bar with no
shirt on and maybe you wanna give a [ __ ]
so we stopped in this [ __ ] restaurant
my god Burger King who knows and like
you know he's talking to people he's
fought with them we'll go go in the
afternoon
we're doing a couple bumps we're already
on acid and I'm going to see deal with
Sabbath you know who was opening for
them the singer from Van Halen when he
was with Sheikh Street that guy that's
in Cabo Wabo uh Hagar Hagar was a band
called shaken Street Oh
Wow and they were saying they were spit
down in Philadelphia that was spitting
on their fingers and flinging the spit
with their fingers
he was onstage duck attention it was
[ __ ] hysterical why don't they like
Sammy Hagar I don't know I don't ask
questions
I see people get spit on me I find my
business but my man
Darrin came back and that was his name
that Rago god rest his soul he came back
into the carnitas look dawg
look what I got I got acid right and it
was just it was microdot mmm but those
days the hot acid was Mike without a
paper acid he had got these things that
look like ear plugs that were purple
just a little smaller than ear plugs hmm
I go what type of [ __ ] acid is this
he's telling me it's devil acids he
traded two lines at THC took three hits
acid hysterical so we get to the thing I
told you don't wanna hold on to him I'll
pass there was like six bands it had to
be like a broad band and then it was
Sammy Hagar and then it was somebody
else and then it was Black Sabbath not
only that listen to this one we had like
13 row seats and some guy came up to us
he's like listen man can I talk to you
guys I'm like what's up he goes listen I
can't get reformed my friends and tool
and just beat me for Coke or something I
don't want to sit next to them do you
mind trading your tickets and I'm like
what are you talking about I think goes
I'm sitting at six row center I'm
sitting in thirty ship and you want
these ticket singles I'd rather sit with
where you're sitting and sitting next to
these two [ __ ] let me see if it's
legit right on the arena we walked right
through the seats I shook his hand he's
like [ __ ] you to his friends [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] barfs loose in
the six row son so he isn't me and Aaron
on the purple BAM
so at first the music was great you know
I'm watching these people spit at Sammy
Hagar it's phenomenal
didn't you get hit by something in the
six row no no Black Sabbath comes on and
DL comes out there with his little devil
finger generals gathered at his masses
just like which is a black masses and
he's saying all this not like all this
is a Fugazi say something to guarantees
out on the floor he's on the floor
sleeping so at one point I'm like I said
we got to get out of here so I pick him
up and he's like holding our arms over
each area method if not we throw them in
the Black Sea like what the [ __ ]
happened to him and we're driving home
as well he woke up he woke up like angry
like well I got what happened those
purple quaaludes right because we can't
call them purple quaaludes you know
saying hey [ __ ] quaaludes that was
pure acid I was tripping into things
like ugh the other time you were
tripping was on the floor you know we
taught menthol from 1982 the day you
died about the purple quaaludes every
time he got again quite loose they're
not purple water [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know
those who acid I know I saw things we
called them purple loot so the day he
died doesn't purple loot [ __ ] you what
time we robbed the gas station every
night and another guy on the Friday and
the cops are looking for I don't know
they didn't know there was no cameras
nothing we are like 800 900 damn we just
hit the guy in the head with like a new
Chuck just because money and we shot
down this short and I'm good way down
and we stopped out of a ball like that
was our plan like we each got a we each
got an Eightball we walked away with
like 60 to 50 so then we get the seaside
we're going to jail for an eight ball on
62-52 eight balls three eight balls on a
piece at 250 apiece at 750 and we had
like 200 left over we robbed a gas
station for like 980 little short of a
thousand so we got three eight balls we
fill the car up with gas and we chopped
with the rest of the money three ways
that's how part let's do it so we're
driving how the show we got a hotel room
that's a small four there's a 6215 yeah
then we got away with beer so we're
sitting there down
me and some of the I think it was stinky
it's gotta be 82 or [ __ ] getting
coked up to the gills and all send me
here and right there it opens the
curtain it's like a Haitian maid I'm
blacker than black and she's yelling in
Haitian and I know if we get gonna [ __ ]
you and like closing the curtain it's a
woman out there yelling at some language
that never heard before I'm like Doug
mutation just leave her alone she won't
come in she tried to [ __ ] open the
door he's young and I'm gonna knock her
out if she comes in huh he cannot cut
the [ __ ] nation made did he go past
check-in let's check out or something
what happened I don't [ __ ] know we've
said this whole time the eight-ball woke
up the next thing we went back home
depressed yes they said no [ __ ]
reason and that no I was just gonna ask
you that sound like there's a gun guy
sends a decent guy you're even more of a
decent guy they don't do things like
this you understand me only animals like
me have a good time it's funny because
now I sit back and I go you know what
mother half the fun I had because was it
drugs yeah like half the fun way I would
love to sit here and go you know what
don't do drugs and live your life
half the fun I had was the adventures
either getting the drugs doing I mean I
ended up kidnapping somebody put them in
the chocolate car I laughed my ass off
about that today nobody got hurt
[Laughter]
violence nobody got hurt he's a little
psychologically scarred oh he's got PTSD
and a couple other things he might have
a rash or something negative right
it did work it's how you look at it it's
how you look at things yeah
jail was exactly what I needed at that
thing
a couple of weeks away from society who
gives a [ __ ] it turned out to be a
positive somebody okay it got me ready
for the next 20 years what would have
happened if I wouldn't got caught dead I
wouldn't got caught now and let me tell
you something being in jail when you're
50 is a lot harder than being in jail
when you
[ __ ] when you're 20 you got least fight
to the death when you're 50 you're
getting [ __ ] in the ass I was thinking
about that last night about that scene
from American me know from the Sons of
Anarchy when the guy who wrote and
directed is getting like assaulted in
his cell every day he bites his tongue
off in other words picked up the ass by
one big black pig and the guy eats his
lunch would mate City without you were
trying to say we yeah sure I was trying
to keep it PG for a second we don't keep
it PG he's getting sexually assaulted
they show that other sons of I've never
seen it
yeah they sure yeah [ __ ] I'm so exam
spoiler it's like 10 years ago so yeah
if you ever watch some zanuck even
there's no spoiler attack it shows been
canceled for [ __ ] years don't get a
[ __ ] life spoiler a little gives a
[ __ ] I would tell them talk about the
episode the next day and people get
pissed do I watch the [ __ ] thing with
commercials the first time yeah well
they're so there's no besides I gotta
watch you're not really a fan yeah me
and my wife we go to dinner we get home
five to seven I take three hit to the
pipe and Sons I haven't even come on I
have to meet that shower give a stab and
it's date night
everybody gets a [ __ ] everybody has a
good time bah it's no big [ __ ] deal
no you come here often boom done yet
died looking okay that girl that poor
girl they live before years never came
it about what do you got this show
nothing not one shot to the mountain uh
well let me let me ask you this with yes
was like was that something that you
guys just agree though yeah he took our
stand
yeah I mean I asked and I'm not if
someone says no I kind of leave it there
and I want to push the envelope you've
never asked you just pop the load they
mouth and let them wait for the reaction
where did I mean whether and she told
you know morning sex and you bought into
it okay she doesn't like sex in the
morning no Olivia I love sex you can't
live like cuz I'm gonna give you a stab
in the morning I told you I don't like
listen it doesn't really matter what
I'm paying the lights I'm paying the
[ __ ] food bill here you driving back
and forth to work nobody sucking dick
you know what to say but we can't think
no you have to say it because if you
don't say it then look what happens
exactly four or five years later and you
haven't come in a month yeah girl
telling me I'm coming them out that's
the first thing I do I knock away you
know I'm saying if a girl tells me like
on a date I really don't like when guys
come in my mouth I drink a milk shakes
another thing I shoot a load in the
mouth that she'll never [ __ ] come
back again or she'll come back for ya
coming out her ears and she I don't have
time for that [ __ ] since day one I
played that I'm a romantic game for a
while I'm thinking you're [ __ ] in the
ass they tell me what they don't like
and that's the first thing I do I don't
like when the guy flocks in my fight
when I'm getting a [ __ ] that's the
first thing I do is blow a [ __ ] nut
right in their face I don't give a [ __ ]
if they pull away I come in their eyes
so be it
so did you I mean was it like a healthy
sex life
leave her I mean no no he's damaged he's
damaged it was it was four years in and
another down towards the amber that
happens but yeah I mean but did you like
29 yeah listen when I date that stripper
I [ __ ] her every day for four years I
got my money's worth on that dirty [ __ ]
every day except for a period I did
something to her those five days I stand
away from my like a leper because she
had to him but then that sixth day I
give her a stabbing him by the egg that
beaten up [ __ ] an ass and finger to the
depth and the blood came out again oh my
god
that stripper I remember how breaking up
a Mimi going you think I really care
that you broke up with me I [ __ ] you
every day for four years I got my
money's worth I do you filthy animal
every piece of sushi every bottle of
wine your romantic yeah because when
you're not sucking and [ __ ] and they
oughta wine at $60 a pop and you're
sitting there getting angry yeah you
know you came into hair you [ __ ] away
I put a bottle of the [ __ ] one time and
it sucked the period juice out I did
things that poor girls I had a good time
I know easier to farm alum know what
still friends because she's an animal
she even told me she's still an animal
fifty she's a [ __ ] animal but no
every day I got your money's worth
yeah
I give you a grandma coke too don't get
my money's worth daddy there's no way
you're leaving here alive
nobody's much for free you suck in
something you give me a teddy show I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm feeling something
I'm no Harvey right I'm no [ __ ] half
a face what the [ __ ] I'm this city and
give you half my blow yeah you're not
gonna suck it I gotta hear stories about
your boyfriend not on this planet
I think people take blow a little bit
more seriously then I took like ramen
and stuff cuz I didn't butter dinner and
that was we have four four [ __ ] years
that were terrible and that up that you
got talked into wait online her
girlfriends all those bad concert she
went to Long Beach for New Year's
remember that one that was an investment
opportunity the time you went to jacuzzi
and had a scar the time you broke the
zip line I just as if all the Groupons
and all the coupons that adds up and
you'll say now that you won't go to a
strip club listen you go up here that
chick up there for the small 300 you
take you upstairs way too much of the
protein juice are six dinners I guess
this is 180 no six then is that [ __ ]
160 is 360 that's I'm saying for 300 you
up there I think it's 260 you can [ __ ]
[ __ ] in a face and you give her a $40 tip
and you'll be ah you can't you're not
suppose that the cops roll in okay so
you coming on our face today I'm gonna
do it she's on the wait their turn
yeah put the badge away put the gun away
the whip is dead but the put the whip
away the horse is dead deal I'm saying
what do you want from me I think that's
illegal isn't it no it's not illegal you
go off and listen you go an edge dark
what do you think happens in the dark
spots you jerk off that's what happens
we're gonna walking around nude what do
you thinks gonna happen you think those
girls don't go home what's in that once
a week with jizz on that leg
somebody's shooting yeah you go into
that back room up there they do dirty
things to you and then you go upstairs
and they do even dirty things to you
there's upstairs there's upstairs that's
what I'm trying to say to you give them
the 260 that's a lot of money hold on a
tip and you do whatever the [ __ ] 40
and
up all the ramen right so the [ __ ] you
put up with and you spill I can get and
you said it was long Acula and all that
[ __ ]
you give the girl is small 260 you shoot
him I do normally sleep like a baby you
didn't do that that's a day what do you
give a [ __ ] 260 I don't give a [ __ ] how
many times you're going there once a
week who gives a [ __ ] it's better than
sitting at home but looking at four
walls like the guy from [ __ ] what's
that ban at least I got 260 though what
260 you dropped four years of [ __ ]
then I know but nowadays you know after
we save up for the next four years
once they tell you you don't like coming
my mug you go really mean either slow
job you make sure you come double quick
with mushroom juice and asparagus and
you make that Chinese face like
something not right and wrong or they
brush their mouth they Listerine and
it's still stuck in their [ __ ] throat
what you like in me there's a [ __ ] this
is what happens if you like somebody you
got a drink the GU when I'm sucking your
[ __ ] you spray at me what do you think
I get out of the way no I inhale that
[ __ ] day right yes yeah stay right in
there did you guys did you guys do
everything was everything like obviously
not but really no but I'm he didn't pull
a hair he didn't come on the face I
smile you ever done that to anybody I
would have pulled my dick out of him up
and slammed in the mouth with it and put
it back so she doesn't know what's going
on when it comes it comes out and makes
that noise like that like that that's
[ __ ] tremendous and when with that
note what's the tour where's the next
towards darkness when's the next tour
July 11th Europe
really yeah we're in your uh five weeks
month and a half maybe Jesus Christ
somebody had what spot to go to a Europe
Spain Germany France Italy what else
Czech Republic maybe
Ireland UK yeah yeah July 11th - like
August 18th or 22nd
when he's something like that it's like
five or six weeks something like that
and then we're home for two months and
then we're doing another US tour I think
November December but we've got this
this I started this kind of power metal
side project it's like old school metal
and it's called three-headed snake and
we're actually mixing that thing it's an
EP that I hope to have done in the next
like month or two and that's like old
school [ __ ] power metal like from the
80s and [ __ ] like that
i jus degrees yeah it's like that it's
like that kind of just suck inside it's
like it's like a battering ram yeah it's
like classic like priest [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ] just heavy riffs power metal the
singers [ __ ] amazing and Derek
actually track the drums on that thing
so we got that thing going on
two men how is it like a registry for
bad names now how you come up with the
band name and not that hasn't been used
well I mean you do have to you know get
it trademarked and [ __ ]
really but okay yeah all right yeah yeah
what's it cost you know they trade
locker up and they um it's like it's not
that much money
it's like a hundred and something I
thought yeah yeah yeah it's not it's I
mean it's definitely not super expensive
to get it done it's just doing the
paperwork and [ __ ] Sinhala it's been a
pleasure following you want of social
media you don't follow sin
you're [ __ ] missing on it's he shows
you a different type like of what you
think musician's life should be he shows
you some interesting [ __ ] pictures
follow him I don't know if you put
videos up yeah we have yeah we have and
we got a Twitter thing going on now
which I didn't have the last time I was
here because people were after I did the
show people are like one to find about
Edgware twitter it's uh I think it's sin
curing music yep I think since you're a
musical yeah yeah yeah you're a good
soul thank you brother
and I felt bad because I didn't get the
full Petrof from sin I didn't really
know the experience then I started
looking at your pictures and all the
interesting [ __ ] you're doing I
appreciate it man bro you're solid
you're very downer Thank You Man I've
seen with all levels dude and I gotta
say man there's a there's a group on
I think it's on Facebook that it's a
church group yeah it's got curly hair
these [ __ ] guys man did I mean my hat
goes off to those guys because they have
been nothing but amazing to me and
because of the show obviously and
they've been I mean nothing but just the
most supportive guys yeah dude for for
you know supporting all the stuff that I
have going on they've been great people
so I mean I want to say thanks to those
guys and when I was on this last tour a
lot of guys came up man and they were
like [ __ ] heard you on Joey's [ __ ]
show if you go to Europe dude and all
them a lot a cool people manager solid
son it really is dude it really proud of
people that come to the shows
yeah it shows the way that waitresses
always go you don't want man they were a
little drunk and Ronnie but they were
good people very happy decent so thank
you for being here we rate you the best
you [ __ ] yeah do not back down
from anything since your head thank you
and you can plug your main song that's
the website whatever the [ __ ] you need
awesome thank you I appreciate it don't
forget a month right now week from
tonight I'll be in Las Vegas with Lee
taping the special thanks to you people
and Netflix and then on the 16th or some
my time that Colusa Casino is a few
tickets left but before I leave I got to
talk to you about blue apron it's the
number one fresh ingredient recipe
delivery service in the country blue
aprons mission is to make incredible
home cooking accessible to everyone they
achieved this by supporting a more
sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chefs
blue apron or forestry plans you ready
the two-person plan the meal plan meals
that serve two people choose from eight
recipes per week with a choice to
receive two or three recipes any week
the family meal plan
meals that serve for people choose for
new recipes per week with a choice to
receive two three or four recipes any
week and featured upcoming films and
they have a wine plan but listen Lee
what was the last thing you got you said
you just got a dish it was a tremendous
amazing was a beet it was a beef bowl
and had rice beef and I marinated that
head broccoli and a poached egg on top
it was called the Tokyo beef and rice
bowl was delicious
there you go now blue everything is
offering our listeners their first three
meals for free three meals for free when
it comes to cook when it comes to dinner
let blew a pan take care of the planning
and shopping why you do the cooking and
the eating this month you'll enjoy
delicious meals like popcorn chicken
with sweet chili cabbage slaw and cumin
spice wonton noodles and vegetables and
peanuts on the table in 30 minutes or
less with incredible ingredients and
chef designed recipes blue apron lets
you see what the power of food can do
alright we want to hear the food you
love to cook and eat all right we have a
team of professional chefs putting in a
lot of care into creating recipes each
week we need your help I'm bringing this
food to life for your listeners so some
of the best parts of your day happen
over dinner we want you to share that
with your three people you understand me
so when you get the recipe and you're
cooking there with your wife or your
loved one or whoever your uncle or
whatever you're both learning how to
cook you're building a bond which makes
a better family so check out this week's
menu look what they got they got pork
chorizo tacos or radishes roasted
potatoes and cotija cheese salmon and
spicy are in salsa with quick quinoa and
carrot salad whoo creamy pesto cavatelli
with mushrooms and spicy breadcrumbs and
dig this one you ready white cheddar
cheese burgers with balsamic glazed
onion and roasted potatoes are you
kidding me or what I'm gonna give you
your first three meals for free at blue
apron calm slash Joey blue apron calm
slash Joey blue apron a better way to
cook number two listen Fuji Sports calm
that's all I could tell you that's all I
can tell you you're looking for a gig
you start in you Jitsu that
- way to go I don't care if you get the
$99 G or you get the 136 - separate oh
it's gonna be tough dependable and guess
what else
light you ever have again and you don't
even feel you like am I [ __ ] naked no
you gotta Gyan [ __ ] go to Fuji
sports.com right now whether you getting
the shin guards a boxing gloves the muay
thai gloves
listen rash guards they got it all they
always got a sale go to fuji sports
night right now impress in church and
get 10% off the limit right the house
you help off the pot guys everybody
[ __ ] family all right I want to thank
blue apron
I want to thank Fuji sports.com I want
to thank my man sin for coming in
bringing the main man over here in the
air a guy I think you guys [ __ ] word
he's a gentleman he drinks his water he
ain't bothering nobody
I want to thank the Flying Jew but most
of all I want to thank the church family
for being a [ __ ] gentleman tremendous
women and for [ __ ] supporting us in
our cause every week thank you have a
great day we'll be back Thursday morning
ready to [ __ ] rock don't worry about
nothing we love you stay black check
that [ __ ] mule League